[Music]
so much for relaxing khloe kardashian's
nieces crash her bikini photo shoot
leave it to kids to bring the fun and
chaos exactly
these snaps of chloe weren't meant to be
a family affair
but things quickly took a turn when
ten-year-old penelope and nine-year-old
north photo bombed their aunt's beach
picks coco wrote in her instagram
caption quote i swear i'm almost done
with vacation photos my nieces won't let
me live and take my content you just
gotta roll with it the kardashians know
a thing or two about their kids stealing
the spotlight kim had to deal with it
during her tonight show
i'm appearance i'm hearing kids guys can
you stop
saint and some couldn't keep quiet on
set and kim quickly called out her boys
for interrupting her interview my two
toys are here and i hear them making so
much noise guys this is your first time
at work with me don't mess this up
boys will be boys but kim's kids give
her a hard time often having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot during the height of
quarantine the mom mama four couldn't
catch a break from her eldest daughter
north while doing her makeup
what sweetie
okay
okay dorothy
can i wash my hands can you do it in the
other room i'm in the middle of
something i don't want to get this all
wet sweetie one thing's for sure kim has
a system in place for self-care and like
most parents to keep her sanity i'm
hiding in the guest room you guys i'm
hiding in the guest room because my kids
will not leave me alone
hey that's me
and north's cousin stormy seemed to want
in on the action too
when her mom kylie jenner was getting
glam just months after welcoming baby
number two
okay so i know i've been mi for a while
stormy wants to be in this
but i launched a
new lip product
lip lacquers
get out of here
let me do this for two seconds
okay and of course the always patient
stormy is her mom's best helper
[Music]
the now four-year-old took this pic of
kylie's striking a pose and gotta say
she knows how to catch her best angle
the proud mom wrote my babies got me i
love it and even though the kardashian
kids may bring the chaos we love seeing
their little personalities shine and the
reality family grow
i mean it's so much fun the family grows
and and it's getting bigger all the time
and yeah it's really fun to see the
babies have babies
[Music]
you